what is going on guys where am i I'm in
the channel awesome office who is this
guy it's Doug Walker there's tabs our
critic how you doing thanks so much for
joining me on this review yeah thanks
for joining be in my office
yeah we're currently working on a very
special review for channel awesome it's
gonna be out very soon hope you guys
enjoy that a very special episode in
stodgy photos after school specials
tonight we went and saw a movie called
passenger she took me to a really cool
theater here in Chicago Hollywood
Boulevard I talked about all the time.i
reviews if you're near there check it
out beautiful and Hollywood palms
wonderful theaters yeah it was awesome
they served food there was menus and
drinks and everything I've never been to
a theater like that no there's a couple
but this one is like some cool themes
and like themed theaters instead there's
a Casablanca theater that has a starry
sky and a Wizard of Oz it's amazing it
was you know yeah so passengers is
directed by this guy's name who I don't
want to screw up and he made the
imitation game which I thought was a
great film this film stars Chris Pratt
and Jennifer Lawrence and is the tale of
two passengers who are on a spacecraft
traveling to homestead to a new earth of
sorts and they both are woken up in
their hibernation chambers far too early
overall I was excited for this movie I
thought it was really cool-looking I
liked the trailers for it I like science
fiction movies that have isolation
involved I love alien there's some anime
films some really crappy anime films
called Lily Kat Oh crappy animation when
you sell it like that yeah I'd be
excited too I love I love my crappy
anime but I love isolation science
fiction even some of the more shitty
ones and unfortunately I found this
movie disappointingly bland I'm not sure
how you felt it you know uh if you told
me the idea I'd be like okay like that
has potential that has us need stuff and
when I saw the trailer s just are like
okay maybe if there's some twist or
surprise or whatever and pretty much
what you see in the trailer is again I
gained the spoilers or anything but
exactly what you think you're gonna get
there's nothing surprising in this film
at all the actors are just kind of doing
their thing
I didn't even get that much chemistry or
relatability off of them and the whole
film just has it starts off with the
ship being an autopilot I felt like the
whole movie was kind of in that auto
that's a really good that's a really
good example I think they're both very
charming actors obviously yes Chris
Pratt Jennifer Lawrence and I do
actually think they work fairly well
together in the movie I think they're
both good in this movie I just feel like
they weren't given much to do in this
movie because it starts off there's a
lot of shining oh ma jizz I think we all
picked all guys Johnson 2001 gravity
gravity another one I go that's that
movie that's that movie and there's sort
of all these movies nothing really felt
that original outside maybe the design
of the ship like the outside was really
cool it was sort of like a foul screw
yeah into the front it looks almost like
a cell I'm like okay that's that's cool
everything else I'm like okay I seen
that from this movie in this movie in
this movie nothing nothing felt new
about it so some friends of mine read
their original script for this movie it
was on the blacklist for many years
which if you don't know is a list of
unproduced scripts that are very popular
and according to them there is a
revelation of sorts that occurs in the
third act of that script that this film
took and put in the first act so that we
know ahead of time what's going on and
according to my friends it was a lot
more of an impact on the script when you
learned these details later
you kind of understand yeah no I do and
honestly watching this film again won't
give anything away but I'm watch's
thinking you know if they told this in a
different order yeah when they've been
10 times more interesting yes definitely
you could pretty much tell the exact
same story that did change some things
with like the performances except I'm
like if you just told this a different
order immediately it would got my
attention more I weapon more fascinating
more than weapon twists and turns and
stuff and it's so rare that I say that
because a lot of times they try to tell
stories out of order and it's like
there's no reason for it or it's a
gimmick but here I think that's what
would have made it interest definitely
there are things I like about this movie
I think it's a really well shot film I
think the special effects are beautiful
there's a really cool sequence where the
ship loses gravity and Jennifer Lawrence
is swimming and the water sort of floats
up into the room and
collides with each other it's a
seamlessly blended movie for me in
between the CG and the the real-life
effects I think it's a really great
looking movie I like the music - it's a
little overstated at times boy now it's
just about to say yeah cuz your rights
not bad music but there are times where
I'm like if there was no music here
again it would just make some a these
scenes better yeah you feel the
isolation more it is a little overstated
at times but I like some of the themes
of the composer did I miss - who
composed the movie Thomas Newman
is that it oh yeah well he's a great
composer and a little loud sometimes in
regards to this movie I enjoyed I would
say the first act quite a bit I like the
setup for four passengers I liked Chris
Pratt and Jennifer Lawrence wandering
this ship trying to figure out what's
going on it's just that along the way
the film failed to really impact me or
give me a reason to get into it anymore
and eventually towards the third act
there's another sort of thing that just
kind of happens and they have to deal
with it and it's so brief and so quick
and just thrown away in a second that it
felt almost like they were like hey they
should probably do something well we'll
just have him do this with that and it
was just like nothing it had no real
impact on the story other than to be
like hey here are some things on the
ship you didn't know about so we need a
way to explain that to you so we're just
gonna give you this little thing to
happen and to me it felt really out of
left field a lot of the film cap feels
like it's building up to something you
know just something yeah and every time
you think that something has come it's
like oh no that was nothing and then you
say oh here's another something no no
that was really nothing - and then when
it's all done your can like was this it
was this really what it was all
amounting to and even when you do get to
the end you're like I feel like five or
six Platteville's or ways around this
series you know it's true there's even
you know again without spoiling anything
like literally the last few shots
feature an actor that's just in this
movie like he's just there I'm like what
doesn't even get a line it could have
been an extra or anybody but no we had
to have this person I guess he's
probably friends of the director or
something something yeah I guess just
from where it started maybe I'm just
boiled with good movies and stuff like
that but maybe cuz I have seen kindness
idea done before visually it's ain't
done before I've kind of
these actors do this thing before uh
well none of it was like awful I never
rolled my eyes and said oh this is
stupid uh nothing
grabbed me about it nothing seemed
extraordinary nothing seemed like hey
God here's something new that we're
gonna do and we're really gonna or even
something old we're gonna put a new
twist out just nothing popped out at me
at all so it's not a film I think is
like terrible because this is getting
really panned by critics I don't think
it's necessarily worth that I also agree
I don't think it's that bad either but
but it's just there's nothing that
interesting about it yeah I think that
really is what boils down to it for me
it's a film that could have been really
cool and has some investing scenes and
has some investing character moments and
it does have a slight moral twist in
there about their romance and it gives
you sort of a what-if scenario where
you're like man what if I was in this
scenario and it makes you ask those
questions but then it doesn't really
have the guts to really push it farther
and so in the long run I'm not really
going to recommend that you see
passengers I think it's a good-looking
movie with good performances I'm gonna
give passengers a c-plus I would give it
a c-minus very pretty much see we'll
compromise and say see ya I say if you
watch the trailer and you're like oh
that this looks enjoyable this looks
like a good movie if that's we think out
of the trailer you'll probably like it
fine um but if you're looking for twists
and turns and surprises or something you
know really new you you're not gonna get
it here well guys thank you so much for
watching our review of passengers as I
said is my buddy Doug Walker check out
channel awesome I've linked their
channel in the description below we're
doing something really cool very soon
for a very cool movie might have some
Star Wars people in it a couple Cup
might look forward to that thanks for
joining everybody thanks I ever make it
was great to have you on and as always
guys if you liked this you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Applause]
[Music]